I get a call from the police
um summoned to the police station
um
and eventually the police press charges
against me and against the two uh hosts
of the program claiming that we were
advertising so-called conversion
practices by a bit simply because we we
talked about my experience and I because
I answered questions about conversion
therapy
foreign
Blakely from Noah's love Ministries and
I'm a guest on the LED set today as is
Daniel a couple of your regulars here
are Mikey and Keith
and we have an amazing program for you
today with Matthew greck from Malta
who has been in the news lately all
around the world Matthew left the LGBT
community he's going to share his
testimony and then the sequel to this
the program that will come right behind
this one is uh about what he's been
dealing with in Malta today just from
sharing his testimony and so Matthew
thank you so much for joining us I'm
really grateful for you to to be with us
and to share your testimony today thank
you for having me it's a joy to be with
you all so Matthew I'm looking forward
to your testimony today and I was
wondering if you might start off by
telling us about
um where you grew up how you grew up and
what things were like for you yes so
when I was young I was very musically
inclined I would say
um definitely not the stereotype and
typical uh boy if I had to compare
myself to other boys my age
um so you know I was kind I was uh
sensitive to others never wanted to harm
anyone I was raised uh in a in a
Catholic environment so I remember times
where I would pray with my grandmother
and she would have a written prayer that
involves the Holy Spirit and I used to
enjoy
um that time with my grandma and just
that sense of devotion
um I remember times uh when I was young
being with my parents and my my older
brother who's three years older than me
and my sister who's one year younger
than me we would be gathered together
and and praying
um the the best way my parents knew to
guide us to pray however I wouldn't say
I I had a a real or tangible experience
of God
um in my childhood
um eventually
um yeah I I remember uh growing up I
you know I I I started to feel a sense
of pressure to perhaps conform a little
bit to culture my father loves football
to this day he always loved football and
sports and so did my brother but I
wasn't really interested
now of course when I look back that
doesn't that never made me any less of a
man but
I just wanted to be understood I wanted
somebody to speak my language but
um I couldn't really fit in with my
brother and my father that much they
tried to introduce me to football
classes but there was a resistance from
my end and it made me feel embarrassed
actually because it felt like I should
do this but I'm not able to so it brings
the sense of Shame So eventually I think
my mother noticed that I was finger
tapping on tables and she thought that I
might be a good pianist so my parents uh
you know introduced piano lessons for me
and that was going very well and I think
it was my little world where I could
escape from all the stress of trying to
perform and to be the the boy that that
I was expected to be and just enjoy this
creative world of music
um
So eventually I remember that as a
family you know we moved to France I was
uh nine years of age
and everything was fine you know I was
um I started to you know think about
relationships and other girls and how
I'm going to relate to school kids and
etc etc but something happened when I
was in France um I was at home and I
didn't realize that some television
stations
um involved
um you know just lustful material so I I
stumbled upon a TV channel that uh was
just very lustful and erotic and it
messed up with my brain you know I felt
so violated and it kind of Awakened me
sexually before my time I would say and
without my consent really I'm really
sorry that happened because it opened
the door to a lot of lust in my life and
addiction
um just specifically referring to
um you know pornography um
so
there I was and I I started noticing
that I could
search for this material myself instead
of just uh stumbling upon it and you
know internet started to become more
popular and so I started viewing this
content
um in secret you know it was shameful
for me and I knew that something was not
right about it
um but eventually I noticed that I was
inclined to looking for
um men and not for women and that just
made me feel more
um ashamed and and lost I hid it from my
family of course I was asking questions
about myself you know what's wrong with
me this is not normal uh Etc and
eventually
there comes a time where as a family we
move back to Malta and now I'm in
secondary school and
um you know there's peer pressure in my
teenage years to conform to to date
girls you know and I I wanted to look
normal
and I wanted to be like other boys so I
I started trying to date girls and I
managed to date a few popular girls that
made me look you know like I could make
it with my friends Etc
um but there was a lot of insecurity at
one point I managed to be in a
relationship with a girl for like uh
three months I was 16 years of age but
I kind of wasn't feeling what I expected
to feel with a girl so I stopped that
because I was thinking
if I don't perform well with this girl
and she tells her friends and then my
family finds out or my brother or sister
finds out I mean where would that leave
me you know so I wanted to protect
myself I wanted to keep stay safe and I
stopped that relationship
so I was asking okay some things are not
working in my life who am I how am I
going to be happy what does my future
look like can I not be a normal man who
gets married to a woman and has children
why why can't I achieve that you know
and I just felt like such a victim of
unwanted sexual desires I didn't want
these desires it's just that I didn't
know a way out and it was becoming
popular on social media to declare your
sexual
um desires or you know what you're
inclined to so about quite I saw this
popular dancer in Malta who claimed to
be bisexual and this curiosity arose
inside of me okay let me message him and
I wanted to experiment to see how I felt
with men
so I dated this man and you know and
and it felt right for me and my body at
the time as this teenager and I thought
okay so maybe this is who I am then
maybe maybe I like men and that makes me
gay because society says that if you
feel this way then you're to be called
gay and you should accept this and just
go with it if you want to feel fulfilled
and feel happy in your life
um so I dated a few other men you know
and I didn't really manage to find a
love that I was able to sustain and and
I didn't manage to find compatibility in
Malta
um but then I moved to London
to try and make it in my music career
because I was I was becoming a popular
singer in Malta as an r b vocalist I had
a stage name at the time it was called
Jay omaro
um and I was nominated for some Bay
Music Awards and multi Music Awards as a
best newcomer best male artist I was I
was uh really going up the scale but I
moved to the UK because it was a dream
of mine to to make it in the British
territory and even more so in American
territory but
anyway
I'm in London and London all of a sudden
Imagine This Island boy who moves
country goes to London which is so gay
friendly and now it's like this big city
life oh yeah I can be who I want I can I
can do what I want my family will not
fight out yay you know so
and then you know at this gay boys in
London and it just felt like I could
really avoid a lot of Maltese pressure
in London city and I start this
relationship with with uh with a man and
it's more serious than any other
relationship that I had in the past
um and he starts talking to me about
Jesus because I was actually very
interested in New Age practices at the
time I wanted to become a Reiki master
practice the laying on of hands
um for healing but these are not
Christian practices I didn't know better
at the time it's just that I felt like
it was very interesting to seek higher
power and to heal people with the power
of your intention it was very seductive
for me so I try to attune myself to this
key energy to try and impart it to
others
at the time and and this man that I was
in a relationship with was had a bit
more of a strong Christian upbringing
although he didn't reject homosexuality
in his life he was still practicing
homosexual
but I did see something different in him
I think this conviction that he had
about the word of God
was something that spoke to me my father
hooks like like he connects me to this
woman
to help me to find accommodation in
London and he doesn't know that she's a
Christian and she asks me about my
interests and I tell her oh you know I'm
into a new age I love the the idea of
trying to read people's mind and try to
unlock your brain's potential and and
energy and healing and she said Matthew
she said be careful don't just let
anyone lay hands on you like that
instead because you don't know what
Spirit people bury whether it's good or
bad I said okay she said why don't you
come to church
um with me sometime and you know it
would be lovely to see you and at first
I was a bit resistant you know
um but because she was very kind to me
and helpful I wanted to respect her and
I I went along
and I come into this space of prayer
spontaneous prayer that is
spirit and Edge and I come into the
space of just feeling welcomed and loved
among these Christians in London and I
was very surprised
um to encounter something that is so
genuine in a Christian environment
and um
and I was thinking how beautiful are
these prayers how do they manage to pray
like this and they're not even reading
prayers like I used to when I was young
they're just flowing like a river
and I I wanted What They Carried so I
was invited to go to the main service
and again the worship is beautiful and
I'm seeing a drummer and church a drop
um and um and it just felt so vibrant
and Alive
um
and the pastor started having words of
knowledge about people without knowing
them personally and at one point
um he describes a migraine and I
literally had a migraine uh that day and
I looked around to see if anybody raised
their hand because people were being
identified you know by the Holy Spirit
and nobody did and my heart was racing
and I lifted my hand then all of a
sudden he pointed his finger at me and
he said Matthew I sense that God wants
to tell you that he really loves you
that really pierced my heart
and for the first time I encountered the
love
of
a heavenly father who knows me and loves
me and I wasn't the same I couldn't
believe that I'm in the space people are
around me and God would speak to me in
front of everybody and and boast about
his love for me
and that that was something I never
experienced before but I would say that
when I look back I guess I needed a lot
of information I needed belonging I
needed to to to be genuinely loved
unconditionally so
yeah so that was at that transforming
experience and then you know I'm not I I
guess as an American
people have a lot of church experiences
but in Malta we were very limited
because the movement of the Holy Spirit
only began stirring mostly in the late
70s 80s in Malta so we don't really have
Christians who were who grew up as
Christians in Malta so for me all of
this stuff was really really new
um
and
um and I'm invited to receive prayer and
I'm feeling what to receive prayer how
does this work you know and I move
forward and I don't know how to posture
myself I just you know close my eyes and
I was not used to receiving you know
like how do you receive you mean I don't
have to do anything I just stand here
and receive from you guys but it felt
like such an honor to um to receive
prayer this was a beautiful Act of love
that ministered to me I never received
that when I was younger
um although I worked I was a worship
leader in the Catholic church but
um
there was never like a personal Ministry
that touched my heart in this way
um
and I mean this could have been any
denomination you know I I value what I
received when I was young
um and we just go from glory to glory
don't we in our lives it's a journey and
um
yeah so
and then all of a sudden like this this
day passes and I'm filled with this
intense hunger and desire to know God I
said if God loves me then I want to get
to know him
and
and I I bought a Bible I bought my first
Bible and I I was so desperate to know
God I I thought that I could read the
New Testament in a week and be perfect
in a week but I was like I really wanted
to just like make things right with God
you know I had the Holy Spirit was
staring inside of me you know I keep
going to church you know I on and off on
and off you know sometimes I felt like
oh I can't go to church because I'm not
holy enough I'm not worthy to be among
the saints you know I had a lot of
strange ideas at first
um but homosexuality was never addressed
from the pulpit I managed to bring my
boyfriend at the time with me to church
and he experienced it and everything but
he didn't he wasn't like consistent he
didn't want to come again and I was
racing I was running for Jesus I was
addicted to the presence of God I
realized that as I put on Hillsong as I
put on this worship music at home this
energy was filling the room and remember
I was into greatly I was very passionate
about
energy I was a feeder I wanted to feel
the energy and the presence of God
is energy itself isn't it like when
you're fellowshipping with Holy Spirit
you can feel him in the room and so I
was there
and I was enjoying the sense of peace
and joy as I stung to God and I mean and
I was in this perfect balance in Harmony
and I spent nights just worshiping at
one point I only slept for two hours all
I wanted to do was to love on Jesus and
to sing to him and to adore him and I am
reading the Bible and I stumbled upon
verses about homosexuality in the New
Testament
and
okay you know First Corinthians
homosexual uh homosexuals don't inherit
the kingdom of God
and dang I'm like what
I'm thinking Hmm
but is that talking about me because
like for me it feels pretty natural I
don't think it's it's talking about
people like me maybe it's talk about
straight men who mess around yeah that's
bad because you know they're just
you know they're just abusing but me
like it feels natural I was trying to
reason this out but was trying to make
sense of it all
but I had the fear of God and I was
thinking God you know I was praying Lord
I don't want to like try to find
loopholes in your word I wanna do what
is right in your eyes even if it costs
me all I want is to please you and to be
at peace with you and I started the
Greek words for homosexuality and
this understanding hit me that
homosexuality as a word was describing a
practice an act
and this I was introduced through the
word of God so this idea that you know
homosexuality is not an identity
primarily it's a practice so if it's a
practice then you can stop that practice
if you stop it God doesn't see you as a
homosexual anymore
so it's this idea that yeah Matthew you
might have not chosen your feelings but
guess what you can make a choice around
those feelings
and and this brought me so much hope
because it felt like Society thought me
to
taught me that I don't have a choice
actually around my feelings if I want to
be happy but actually now I found
happiness and joy in doing the will of
God
and so therefore I could make a choice
to be happy and and I could deny that
homosexual acts when I understood that I
am telling you this Spirit of heaviness
and this weight left my body and my
spirit and it brought me hope I said wow
so I don't have to be homosexual I don't
have to call myself gay I never have to
come out to my family which is the very
thing that I I never wanted to do it's a
day that I never wanted to face in my
life and I was like what I mean
is this even possible this is amazing I
can be the man that God called me to be
and and nothing else
and I was happy I was happy like the
word of God brought me so much hold
to to be the man that I struggled to
become but actually now it was more
possible than ever you have a question
for you
um yeah I'm listening to you actually
several questions but but this one's
probably most relevant at this point
when or did
that realization start to apply to other
areas of your life because I'm hearing
you talk about it in the context of of
homosexuality which for uh for some
people that that idea of they they're
like okay I can't I can't relate to that
because that that's not me it never was
me but did you did you come to a point
where you said
wow God is the Agent of Change in my
life for this
so that means God can be the Agent of
Change for my life
in these other areas of my life like I
don't have to be
angry or frustrated I don't have to be
this way or that way like God can just
create me new in all of these areas did
that did that happen for you after that
and how long you're right uh there was a
time uh where I was reading the Bible
and I I found a verse that says you know
love the Lord your God and the gospels
you know it says lovely Lord your God
with all your heart and soul and
strength and mind and I it was a it was
such a reality check for me and I
realized you know God wants all of me
and I spent 19 years of my life so far
and I don't feel like I've given him a
fraction of what he's asking from me and
and I started weeping on my bed my Bible
was open my boyfriend was next to me on
my bed and I'm in this complete
different Zone where I'm weeping uh with
this intense desire to to give God
everything
and that was just it was The Godly
sorrow that led to repentance repentance
amen and um and eventually then I I
realized that I could be baptized I
could I could declare my faith in Jesus
and and give up my old man and become a
new creation in Christ So eventually you
know I realized that I I had more
Mastery over
um you know sexual urges in my life I I
definitely had a peace that would guide
me in turmoil in in difficult
circumstances uh and you know when
people try to maybe manipulate me
emotionally I could hold my peace
um there was more more joy that invaded
My Life
um I used to struggle with a lot of
frustration so people would speak to me
and I would be very short-tempered
because there was so much that was just
clogged up you know so that there was
chaos Within Me but
I I was able to be a bit well to be
loving with people and not be Snappy and
frustrated all the time because I don't
know who I am anymore you know like
finding Security in God made me more uh
tangible and more inviting as a man more
inviting as a friend to people because
who wants to be friends with somebody
who is who's frustrated and snappy you
know
um and so uh yeah
um so much so so much
um and I think it's also
you know this this sense of performance
you know maybe I was I tried to find
approval from people through my gifts
and my singing because I never thought
that people would find me appealing for
anything else you know but now you know
manifesting and radiating Christ you
know
makes all of us uh Men Who
who are more desirable and likable and
more approachable you know and and that
made me feel more valuable and that I
didn't have to live my life based on
performing all the time
and and so I was able to be more
vulnerable and more real and honest with
other people and not trying to be
someone who I'm not eventually I
rejected my altar ego and my stage name
and I thought you know what I think Jay
omaro is is buried in Christ man I think
he's amen the old man will try to be
popular and cool but actually
um the real Manatee was is just really
not trying to be popular cool he's very
chilled he's he wants to be kind and
compassionate and associate with the
lowly that's what he wants to do you
know so I I just rejected all of that um
as a it was a process of course but yeah
I think that's that's how I how I saw
Jesus moving in all these different
areas good question yeah I'm sitting
here I'm thinking of the the Bible verse
that says you know if any man is in
Christ he is a new creation you know old
things are passed away behold you know
all things have become new amen it's
exactly what your experience sounds like
so thank you I'm curious about your age
is this happen when you're 19 years old
um yes this journey for me started uh
yeah at the age of 19. you're already
you had a serious boyfriend and you
became you were getting a name for
yourself in the music world and all
those things
so I'm I'm curious to hear more of your
story because how does this relate to
your boyfriend who actually intrigued
you about Christianity who seemed to
have like less of an interest in church
and things but now you have an interest
is this part of your story too can you
continue from there
yeah that's a good good question so yes
eventually you know I'm convicted
through the word of God you know
homosexuality is not from me I must end
this relationship because it does not
give glory to God so
I decided to face my partner at the time
and I told him you know
uh we gotta end this
um this is not pleasing to God and I
really wanna pursue Jesus in my life and
I want to please him and unfortunately
you know this has has to stop we can't
we can't do this together anymore uh
it's not right before God and initially
there was this kind of emotional
manipulation and you know hey you're not
the only one who's got plans with God
you know there was a reaction
and uh but I was I was very firm uh in
my decision I was I felt like I was
standing on very Solid Ground of the
word of God
uh you know once you're convicted you're
convicted like there's nothing that has
not stop you right
um and so I had joy and I had Comfort
throughout this process it wasn't
necessarily easy to let everything go
because we were you know sharing an
apartment together and and you know flat
expenses in London are through the roof
so you know like I had all the reasons
you know not not to do that almost but I
just had to put my trust in God to
provide your head
um
and um
yeah So eventually he chose to you know
keep going with the homosexual lifestyle
unfortunately and um and I and then
there came a time where we stopped
living together and I was uh fully able
to move on uh in my walk with the Lord
so yeah it's it's unfortunate that you
know well this man is is not yet walking
with the Lord as the Lord would desire
but I believe a time is coming where the
Lord will really arrest his heart and
and that he'll be a faithful disciple as
well so that's how things progressed
with us yeah so so I'm in this space you
know you know as a 19 20 year old now
where okay I gave up homosexual acts I
gave up uh the homosexual relationship I
was in now what you know like I don't
see myself with a woman and
um you know I'm happy to be single all
my life that's how I was thinking
um and and I would comfort myself with
the scriptures uh polls with the fact
that Paul was a single man who who
achieved so much for the gospel and the
kingdom of God and I was so inspired by
his example and I thought you know Jesus
was single always single
um you know these single men you know
managed to do a lot in their lives maybe
I can I can be single as well but
actually
I was
I was in a comfort zone and I was using
this these scriptures because I think in
reality
I didn't know
how to get free from same-sex desires
or I wasn't fully introduced I I didn't
have support in this area so I just
thought that you know maybe I just now
have to live a life of abstaining and uh
but I I don't think that's the Full
Gospel you know the gospel offers more
hope than that yeah but I just didn't
have the right support so I I was stuck
in this
single for Life mindsets you know never
will be able to be a husband and have
children but I'm happy to be single
because I gave my life to Jesus anyway
you know
um but at one point it felt like I was
asked okay Matthew let's reason
a little bit together it's homosexuality
was legal in God's eyes and his law
would you still be true would you still
choose to be single or your life or
would you choose to get married you
wouldn't know what the answer is
exactly and I thought
I think I would choose to get married
and so I I realized that there was
conflict I was like so but am I in touch
with myself
do I know what I want this is complex
for me does that mean that I actually
desire marriage and I actually decide
I'm I'm attracted to marriage it's just
that I'm using the single
celibacy concept as an excuse or maybe
I'm just stuck in that cell because I
don't know how to get out by this time I
moved back to Malta
um yeah I think my time expired in
London and it was time for me to come
back to Malta and I I joined a very
healthy Church in Malta as well
um and you know it's just filled with
the power of God and
but I I I still you know the Bible
doesn't necessarily give you a seven
step program of how to get free from
sins desires right and with partner
between Ministry and Malta was pretty
much non-existent and it felt like
as a Christian it was a bit sad you know
because it's just not enough to hear
from the puppet homosexuality is a sin
you know thank you for that act you
gotta yeah and deal with the ads and
then you have to repent okay yeah but
good luck so you're you know I'm I'm so
um I'm jumping the gun I'm I'm you come
back you're immersing yourself into a
church congregation and you have a
history of same-sex Behavior what did
you were you open with that did you hide
that how was the church were they
receptive to you what was this like yes
good question
um So eventually I I realized that this
church was
people on power of God uh really wanted
to it's Apostolic and we want to impact
the nation and we're bold and we're
unashamed that we don't we're the
pastors is very clear-cut with the word
of God and addresses homosexuality from
the pulpit it does not hold back from uh
being truthful and bold with the word of
God and controversial topics like
homosexuality as well so I felt like it
was a safe space to just be real and
open because nobody's gonna be surprised
you know
and I I did share about it with my
pastor and uh you know they were excited
that somebody you know had left
homosexual lifestyle and joined their
Church you know because it felt like a
trophy for the church for some reason
like yeah or homosexual you know so
um
eventually
um yeah
um there came a time where more former
LGBT joined my church River of Love in
Malta and the pastor was getting excited
because he was seeing what the Lord was
doing and how he was bringing these men
and women out of LGBT into God's kingdom
and he had this idea why not we have a
knight a special night at church where
it's fully dedicated to excel gbt
testimonies from the church
and we'll actually create a Facebook
event order and call it gay no more
Changed by the love of Christ wow
yeah and he had he created it and we
were gonna have this night in church and
then
for the first time I think in malta's
recent history the LGBT Lobby protests
in front of our church premises
and they're upset you know and we
weren't even parading this stuff in the
streets it was at the church it wasn't
our own home it was very intrusive I
guess
um but the news picked up on this and
suddenly the forces of darkness and
Malta were realizing that a Remnant a
powerful Remnant was being raised in
Malta by God and that you know the the
Full Gospel of Jesus Christ is being
preached and there is a resistance to
the LGBT agenda that God was stirring up
and raising in Malta
now is that in this recent event or was
this was this before this recent event
that occurred
um so this is a a few years back I think
it was around 2014. okay before the laws
came into place yeah
but this is a YouTube uh video about
this cold picketing the pastor in Malta
if you type picketing the pastor a month
I will come up okay yeah there's some
footage and so I had a lot of
opportunities after this to share my
testimony on malta's top television
programs so all of Malta at first it was
well it was not easy because I I started
to feel very
responsible to speak up about anything
the lgbtw does to try to promote the
normalization of homosexuality in Malta
um so I started to become a voice in
this area and uh somebody who seemed to
comment about anything that is LGBT
related from a godly perspective
and at first you know of course it was a
lot of hostility
um eggs gay what are you saying that's
not possible people are going that way
you're ridiculous a lot of literate a
lot of hostility
um and Malta is a small island so it's
just like the word spreads out so
quickly
adding down
yeah and
but slowly this idea was being
introduced in culture that x gay you
know it started to become a reality
because they started to see more voices
come forward and people were seeing that
hey it's not just one now it's another
one and another one here and there
um and so it's still controversial to
this day but I think it's because people
are becoming a bit more desensitized to
it because most people think well if
you're not harming anyone we will accept
you so what LGBT tries to do is to
convince people that our message and
what we do and the way we live is
harmful because that's the only way they
can get the masses to turn against us
yeah because you're literally just
sharing your story I was this way and
now I'm this way and you have people
picketing you when you're doing it in in
a private or I mean a public place but
it's an invitation they somehow assume a
dark cloud even though you know you may
not not be casting one yeah I mean you
think about other forms of
um you know I guess Realms like take for
example like uh somebody who used to be
a porn star right and they they say I'm
that no longer you know I have reformed
and and people are like Yay you know
it's so great and and no problem and and
other things as well I used to be this I
used to be that and no problem yes but
for some reason this one's a problem
yeah because it's a lie people are
deceived into believing that you are
your feelings and that is a distortion
in and of itself
um and when we come into a relationship
with Jesus Christ he gives us a new
identity and that identity is of the
Kingdom of Light and this world is
clouded by the and is being ruled by the
kingdom of darkness so we know that
there is a battle between those two
kingdoms and that's why we're advocating
for freedom for people from who are
being deceived into believing that this
is all that they can ever be when that's
not actually true yeah so it seems like
Matthew that that God is in so you're
what year are you in at that point
would you say like 2015-16
[Music]
yeah because uh it was around uh
15 16 because then in 2015
um the the conversion therapy uh
legislation uh actually and other laws
were being introduced to promote
transgenderism and homosexuality and
civil unions and gay marriage and it was
just this series of laws and changes uh
by uh a progressive so-called
Progressive uh political force that so
traditional a traditional party with
traditional Godly values somewhere
that's completely different it was like
it's not a political party anymore it's
a movement that's going at a complete
new different direction
um and so yeah we were seeing this
massive shift happening in the nation
um
and and and then eventually I had an
opportunity to um
to participate in malta's X Factor
competition uh you guys know about
inspector in America right yeah
I I thought why don't I try you know
like I wanted to challenge myself
musically a little bit I was feeling
like I was not doing much musically and
I thought why don't I just do something
crazy and different
and I I participated and I had an
audition and I was asked questions
personal questions and I
initially I said I'm not going to talk
about Jesus that early throughout the
competition I'm just going to give it
some time and then I'm gonna be on this
Mission and when I feel like it's the
right time I'll I'll share but God had a
different plan you know I I went I
shared so early and uh I said you know
that I left the homosexual lifestyle to
pursue Jesus that I now stand for uh
biblical marriage between one man and
one woman and and initially
um I had a meeting with the producer of
X Factor Malta because there's there was
it felt like there was a battle around
this interview before it went out uh and
one of the judges actually I had a favor
I had favor with that as well
remembered me from when I was still Jay
omaro and now they're seeing this
and and they always believed in me and
they were hoping that through X Factor
they could transform me and make me
someone resurrected tomorrow you know
yeah but actually I I could not like I I
was I could not follow their advice you
know because I wanted to to stay true to
Jesus and and he said Matthew it's good
it's okay but but tone this Jesus thing
down because you will lose favor with
people if you if you continue speaking
about God all the time etc etc
and anyway and I have this um meeting
with the production team of expector
about my pre-ordition interview and the
producer says Matthew we don't find
anything wrong with what you said in
your pre-ordition interview we listened
to it we're fine with it you had every
right to say what you said you talked
about your experience we're going to
Aaron wow and uh and if it was
broadcasting
yeah that's true
yeah publicized
exactly and but when it came out it was
another storm
um and the producer found it so hard to
moderate the hostility and the hatred
and the comments they had to turn off
the comments
um and the mortar's minister of equality
discussed my audition and my comments in
Maltese malta's Parliament
and
politicians started talking about what I
said and please note right after my
audition they showed an audition of a
lesbian couple and in their interview
they were talking about how they got
engaged to one another
and that was right after my audition
yeah of course that was intentional and
yeah and and nobody said anything right
weird about that but me saying that I
don't want to be homosexual anymore
that's not who I am that was a
controversy it's like you could have
said hey I used to be a very promiscuous
person but now I'm I'm gonna be a
Buddhist monk and celibate and they'd be
like oh that's amazing cool path you
know it's almost like you can say you're
gonna be anything unless you're gonna
choose to be a Christian
and and all the while you're I'm sure it
sounds like by who you are you're not
being disparaging to any other lifestyle
or anything you're not you're not
demoting or demeaning or saying you know
anything else you're just saying this is
what I've chosen for myself absolutely
yes that's it and so some people came to
my defense because I don't want to be
pessimistic uh only like uh the nephew
of malta's former prime minister that
defended me
um malta's ex-finance the minister
um Antonio Finnick uh defended me by the
way the nephew of Moses former prime
minister his name is Ivan grecumentov
and um my my church was supportive of
course you know I had to deal with my
family though because
um
you know I I I missed to say this but
earlier on a few years before
um I decided to tell my uh family that I
used to struggle with homosexuality but
now I'm a Christian and I I I don't want
that in my life because before my first
TV program I was like I don't want my
parents to find this out through
television that would be so uh
dishonorable you know I have to say
something and it was it was not easy for
me but I I I I decided to speak to my
mom first and she was washing the dishes
and and I was just having this casual
conversation I said you know mom
um you know when I was a bit younger I
used to struggle with you know
homosexual
uh thoughts and and actions Etc but now
I kind of left that behind because I'm
following Jesus and she froze for a
second then she said drought and said oh
Matty you know I kind of felt that about
you and and then we continue chatting
you know and I I can't remember how how
my dad found out I guess I guess my mom
shared with him or subtle women but you
know she's gonna communicate to her
husband yeah that's the thing I I I
didn't feel very like comfortable
talking to my dad about it but I think
she was the one to do that
um there was a time where my my father
when I was younger faced me about
pornography and he said Matthew I found
like gay pornography material on the
computer like are you watching this
stuff you know and I denied it and I
said oh no dad you know
some friends were sending me this thing
too bad and you know and I was I was not
a Christian at the time but I think it's
important for me to say that I had this
you know encounter with my dad and I I
lied to him at night and I I used to
watch the stuff and I just blamed
friends for it yeah um but I think you
can you can see that uh my Dad tried to
reach out that was very kind of feminine
I believe that he would have been
accepting and understanding but I I just
I think that's the level of
denial that I had towards homosexuality
that's how much I didn't want it like
even if my dad would accept me I didn't
want it
amen I think I think this is the first
realization that I'm having I never
shared this on any interview before but
I'm realizing now like if if my dad was
ready to welcome this in my life and to
be understanding I still lied I didn't
want it
because I think you know God's God's law
is written on our heart you know we have
the Holy Spirit to convict us of truth
and the more we resist that the easier
that thing becomes to do when you sin
once you feel the guilt the shame the
the taboo-ness of it but then the next
time it's a little bit easier and then
especially if you have a crowd of people
saying like this is acceptable embrace
it and then you start kind of going with
the crowd mentality but that does show
that you had that sense of uh the holy
spirit's
sense of Truth you know what is true I
also had thoughts about you know but my
father is married to my mother I don't
want my father to see that kind of
material the fact that he did that
because of me I was I felt ashamed I was
like What if you know what could happen
to my father's marriage we never know
but I thought I would never want to to
kind of display or or kind of show a
sense of homosexuality before my father
because I honored his marriage to my
mother and I don't want anything to
happen to their marriage you know like
these are the things that people don't
always think about but no let's do ah
you know like it I just never had the
courage to to to be that man to do that
so um I kind of jumped a bit backwards
now but
um yeah So eventually I I told my family
and now they know and they're trying to
discourage me they're like because
they're very private people they don't
like these things to go public they feel
like a sense of disgrace you know oh
you're talking about this stuff and
being so vulnerable and open on TV what
are you doing like this is embarrassing
to our family this is how they thought
you know they had to face their
colleagues at work they had to face
other family members oh Matthew's coming
out as x gay was he doing a soap bunny
you know what is he saying it doesn't
make sense does Jesus thing and he's
being so unpopular like and he's going
against the tide what a mess but my
pastor gave me good advice he said
Matthew you know this is a spiritual
battle do not like you have to resist
the enemy's Bluff and and his pressure
you know at one point my my sister
claims to be suicidal Matthew stop
talking about this because I'm going to
take out my life you know and and I had
I I kind of answered respectfully in a
way that I showed understanding towards
my sister hey you know I understand it's
not easy for you but I have to do this
uh to be a witness for Jesus Etc you
know and and I decided to stand on my
ground uh and to realize that actually
those words were confused by the Demonic
to try and prevent me from speaking out
so Matthew we have
um we have two interviews that we're
doing with you and so we're gonna we're
gonna tighten up and close down on this
first portion but before we close out
here there was something that you said
in another interview that was really in
my own experience I was relating to it
and you mentioned that when you came
into the church and you know here you've
left the LGBT world and yet your your
um being mentored and you're developing
really relationships with men within the
church and within the body of Christ
today and you stopped and you begin to
analyze that can do you remember that
that portion of that interview that I'm
referring to and you said I had to talk
to God and say help me not idolize men
right yeah I think um
that's very true because I had
experiences where
I didn't fully understand how to guard
my heart because
um
for me I had a lot of friends uh
friendships with with girls because I
felt comfortable with girls because you
know
um I didn't have to you know try to be
someone who I'm not I felt like I could
just be myself with girls and related to
relate to them a bit better
but I think relationships with boys were
a bit more of a mystery to me but to to
to be approached by brothers in Christ
in church and to be loved and to be and
and for my friendship to be desired by
them was something very new and
refreshing for me
at times it would be like uh surreal and
um
and and to to kind of form these
friendships with men who never struggled
with same-sex attraction who were my age
who were likable and desirable men I
thought you know how do I manage my my
myself and my thoughts and my feelings
how should I receive this you know
because I misread things about their
expressions and I misread things about
their actions and their kindness and I'm
in this reality you know and there's
this
and a hunger to attached to to them you
know that has to kind of go through the
filter of God's word and his presence
and and there were times where I was not
very able to manage that well this is
where I think such Clarity is needed to
anyone that's watching or anyone we
would talk to about having left the LGBT
World they would say in US dealing with
that well then you're still gay and so
they don't understand or many people
don't understand the elements of God
calling us to deny ourselves for him the
difference between Temptation and
behavior
and so I think that makes it you know
you know very real
um as to what we're faced with today I
spent 40 years in LGBT culture and so
just because I gave my life to Christ
didn't mean that same same-sex
attraction didn't go away Jesus is not a
genie I don't just say you know take it
away because many people say you know
pray the gay away and that when you it
didn't go away well sometimes what
doesn't go away it's like somebody who
said God please take this desire for
cigarettes away and for some people it's
gone and for other people they know that
smoking is bad and that every time
somebody lights a cigarette they want a
cigarette but they go aha but God
doesn't want me to have a cigarette so
I'm going to deny myself for him
absolutely I'm curious about your
experience in regards to this process
would you say that you still struggle at
times with an inclination to being
attracted to the same sex do you
consider do you just renounce that at
all do you not have any feelings or
attractions towards other men at all
like I'm just curious about where you
are present day yes very important
question thank you so
um
I realized that you know I I talked
about at a time where I said okay then
you know if the real Matthew finds
marriage attractive that I have to open
my mind I have to stretch my imagination
and start to believe God for the for
what looks impossible he's the God who
makes them everything possible if we
manage so I said and then I have a faith
issue here and I need to apply to God's
highest purpose for my life and then I'm
gonna take his perfect purpose and I'm
gonna mix it with Faith from my end
and I'm not gonna magnify the problem
I'm gonna magnify you yeah now right
amen powerful and so on that shift was
very important because then you know my
I I had to start speaking in line with
faith because that Paul says in Romans
faith is in two places it's not just in
your heart if it is really in your heart
it has to be on your tongue as well yes
and so I realized I need to change the
way I talk about myself you know and I
and when we speak faith
um we are speaking the truth that's
something that I had to understand God
calls the things that are not as though
they are
and so at first I would get my carnal
mind speak to me saying you're such a
hypocrite and a liar you're saying that
about yourself and it's not even
realistic and it's not true but actually
God is like when you speak Faith you're
speaking my language you're speaking the
truth and so I don't I I'm not a liar
when I speak Faith you know because
that's how that's how we see the move of
God in our lives and so amen um you know
I'm being real and and honest here
nobody can claim to be free from
Temptation so I kind of changed it from
seeing it as this fixed orientation to
seeing it as a temptation as an external
Temptation instead of this like residing
uh disposition inside of me and adhere
and just you know what I mean and uh and
so this this Association was a very
powerful thing in my life and as saying
you know and and God began to teach me
as well that you know at the end of the
day it's we're Spirit we're soul and
we're body and attraction works on three
levels nobody I was thinking actually
many
so-called gay men
do not know that they do have
a sexual attraction to a woman it's just
that it might be a bit weak compared to
same-sex attraction but nobody
uh about what they they generally don't
tend to ask themselves do I have a minor
sexual attraction at least to a woman do
I have a 10 or 20 or whatever it is you
know
um and I I genuinely believe that it is
almost impossible for a man to be
completely like unattracted sexually
unattracted to a woman and I I do
believe that there is a bit of a
spectrum that is at work and it depends
on people's background experience uh
coping mechanism in life Etc there are
so many packages Environmental
Management that work but
so I realized actually you know am I
spiritually attracted to a woman well if
I see Jesus in her that's a spiritual
attraction I can already say that I am
attracted to women you know if I see
Jesus in them you know they're
attractive to me you know it depends
what we mean by attraction right so and
then nurses says oh you know how do you
think how how they carry themselves in
their hearts their emotions the kind of
choices they make in life you know a
woman who is making Godly choices who is
compassionate and kind you know and who
walks in love that's that's her soul and
I'm attracted to that and so I think
there are aspects of attraction that we
don't talk about because people are so
stuck and just physical attraction yeah
yes on that if I say I am attracted to
women of course you know like what do
you mean that how can you be a man who
was completely unattracted to women
women are are uh Are Beautiful Creatures
of God and you know and they they have
they can have a wonderful Soul that's
filled with the spirit and their Spirit
can be filled with God as well so Penny
you know and then
of course you know then the physical
comes the physical aspect and
um there's one thing I did I said you
know I can surround myself with failure
stories oh this Christian man I know
married a woman and this and this
happened to him and it didn't work so
why should it work again catastrophizing
like you were saying making the issues
bigger than they really need to be and
but we can still recognize that it
happens though I'm going to cut you off
but yeah what you're saying yeah I
resonate to a lot of parts of what
you're sharing
so good and um exactly and and I said
well you know what I'm gonna surround
myself with good role models with men
who left homosexuality are now married
to a woman they have children they've
done they've been together for years
they have a healthy marriage a good life
uh that that could in good consume the
marriage and I thought that those are
the kind of men that I need to be
surrounded with you know and it's a
choice like what am I going to listen to
am I going to listen to catastrophe am I
going to listen to success to attract
success in my life right about Bad
Company corrupts a good character so I
won good company so
um and and that's where I'm at you know
like I'm open to God's plan for my life
um I I I actively pray about this aspect
of my life and I am I'm open to you know
getting married to a woman that God has
for me but I'm not I'm not like
obsessing with it I'm like actively
serving God actively praying about it
um and and definitely choosing not to be
in a a comfort zone that God doesn't
want me to be in
um and so it's it's a blessing to to be
in this place
um and I know men who have different
experiences who have gone through the
same path but having a different
experience now we don't have to always
understand you know why did they make
the same decision and have different
outcome
um you know people are different they
they submit to God differently they have
different backgrounds different
weaknesses different strengths so how
can we expect them to have the same the
same results right right Matthew
um you're active in your church now and
you you know have an incredible
testimony and I'm going to throw out a
teaser because we're gonna we're gonna
close this out here in the the next you
know 60 seconds
um what just happened to you a couple of
months ago for sharing your testimony
right
um
and I don't want you to go into great
detail I only want to tease her here
because we're going to do a whole nother
program right behind this these are it
is so basically I I did this interview
on um
a liberal platform actually it's not a
conservative platform it's a liberal
platform that is a free speech and um I
get a call from the police
um summoned to the police station
um
and eventually the police press charges
against me and against the two uh hosts
of the program planning that we were
advertising so-called conversion
practices by a bit simply because we we
talked about my experience and I because
I answered questions about conversion
therapy
um as a term uh during the program so
for more information on ex-gay
Ministries or or looking into the
possibility of leaving the LGBT culture
and getting closer to Jesus Christ and
you can go to know his love that's
k-n-o-w
knowhislove.org also I want to throw in
here on this program and on the
following program as well for Matthew to
support you and for what's going on
right now if somebody wants to
contribute to your efforts would you lay
out the email address of which they can
send donation so it's Matthew greck at
live.com all right so you know I
encourage anyone who has been listening
to support uh Matthew you'll want to
look at the upcoming
um program that follows this as it
relates to Matthew Greg sharing his
testimony and having been arrested
simply for that that it somehow falls
under conversion therapy so thank you
everyone for joining us on this program
today uh we're outnumbered by our guests
thank you to Matthew thank you to Wayne
and thank you to Daniel and we
appreciate all of your input on this
helping us create this program uh don't
forget you can always visit us visit us
at
littlelightstudios.tv we're on YouTube
uh you know don't forget to check out
our t-shirts lightwear dot shop and you
can donate on patreon on our website to
help us make more programs like this in
the future Matthew really appreciate
your test testimony and you we know from
The Book of Revelation how important Our
Testimony is when it comes to the word
of God and so just know that if you're
out there and maybe you're struggling
with something in your life it could be
homosexual relationship it could be
something entirely different Jesus
Christ is there for you and he is the
Agent of Change in your life and he can
transform you and make you into
something new which is what all of us
need because we're in a world of sin so
we hope that you will find that to be
the case and we will see you next time
on LED live take care
foreign
[Music]
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you